you know people talk about the
Cliffhanger in season one The
Cliffhanger season two is so far beyond
the cliff like it's just falling into
nothing at that point and it's so
interesting to see what happens from
there but I got to say as somebody who
is just a fan of the show and the
performances on the show to take a
character like Georgia to watch Brienne
just
make people love her uh it's just
something that I've been in awe of since
day one
Sergeant Miller you're under arrest for
the murder of Tom Fuller
the right to remain silent wait excuse
me can you say can be used against you
in a court of law wait what is what is
happening
I mean what I love about the show is how
imperfect all of these characters are
nothing is wrapped up in a perfect bow
because that's not life this show is is
starting conversations about Nuance
about mental health and about our
Humanity so of course of course season
two wasn't gonna end in a perfect
beautiful bow marrying Paul she's
looking at him as they're dancing Her
Fantasy is coming true and then of
course the other shoe drops and this is
why Georgia doesn't dress up there's
this beautiful Montage with the wedding
and everything's you know coming of
roses seemingly and you're just getting
lost in this beautiful moment and then
all of a sudden everything stops police
come in and George is arrested and that
was the most shocking thing for me I was
pretty really shocked because I didn't
really expect Georgia to really run into
much trouble although she does do a lot
of troublesome things she kind of seems
like the person that could get around it
a lot so when I found out and read it I
was kind of really surprised that that
was happening and I was really intrigued
to what may happen in season three if
there is one to come what will happen
with the story and with Ginny and Austin
and with her and just what it will turn
out to be
I knew what was gonna happen I knew from
day one but I didn't make watching it
any easier I think when you're filming
it it's different but when I sat down
and I saw it for the first time like as
an audience member I was so frustrated I
was like why is it stopping I need more
I do think the very end of the season
what happens at the wedding I think the
very end of the season is definitely
gonna surprise everyone another
spectacular Cliffhanger yep and for that
like we wanted to really
emulate what happened at the end of
season one so that shot of Georgia
driving away in the cop car is the same
shot of Ginny and Austin driving away on
the motorcycle yes
it was planned that way we're Geniuses
yeah this family just can't get a lucky
break so
[Music]
for me I think the most shocking part of
season two was when Georgia made the
decision to end
um Cynthia's husband's life I thought
that was a pretty bold move and I
couldn't actually figure out how I felt
about it which I really thought was
really refreshing and really cool and
interesting
um but yeah that was definitely a
shocker for me
yeah I didn't see that one coming I did
I did not want comment at all Georgia
killing Tom
I read that read that to go back in the
script and be like wait did I miss
something did Tom hurt her feelings like
no this girl is just Austin firing a gun
we didn't see that coming
definitely that was it yeah yeah those
two were wild
please don't do this Mark this way
please don't do this
[Music]
I did not expect Ginny and Marcus to
break up at all that is not what I saw
coming and that that was a shocker to me
and in the same hallway I was
heartbroken I remember Felix and I in
the rehearsal that it was a really long
day that day it was like two in the
morning we wanted to go home
you're all exhausted and we had to do
this big breakup scene that was gonna be
really really important
um and we did a rehearsal and just in
the rehearsal we started tearing up we
were like we don't want to do this to
each other
um it's really heartbreaking I mean
these two characters they understand
each other in ways others don't in in
the show and they really do support each
other but I think the key difference
between the two of them is that Marcus
bottles things inside and Ginny's very
much you know like this is what I'm
going through this is what I'm going
through
um so it is heartbreaking to see them
break apart because of their own
personal you know incompatibilities with
how they communicate but I do think it's
extremely mature what they decide to do
later you know when Georgia says I think
Marcus just needs a friend right now and
the lovely scene in 10 where Jenny's
just cuddling him and it's like I'm here
for you I think they'll always be in
each other's lives whatever
shape or form that might take well had
we have yet to see but I do think
there'll always be in each other's lives
for sure Jenny what are you doing
just thinking what it would feel like to
have a heart attack and to suffocate
oh
I don't think it would feel very good
no it sucked we have season three and
season four all planned out so things
that even happen in season two won't
make sense until you see season three
then you'll be like oh they were Red
Cross Yes red comes baby carefully
plotted tent poles to get us to season
three yes we do not have an official
season three so that's why we need all
of those 53 million people to watch all
10 episodes again and that first 30 days
if you need it that was season three in
success of a season three it will also
be a very different season of Ginny and
Georgia we will go in in places that I
don't think anyone could imagine any of
the audience can imagine I also think it
would be a
a very fun season season one we spent
breaking the characters down and then
season two we spend the whole season
kind of building them back up again
um and it takes a really long time so I
think season three is now that we've
done that with them now that they've had
this roller coaster we can really do
whatever we want and also to add what
Sarah was just saying at the end of
season two The CORE family is really
back together yeah and so in season
three it will be truly Jenny and Georgia
and Austin together on the same page
with EV with everything that's happening
so that's a little bit of new territory
that we'll be starting with yeah and I
think our fave this last thing I'll say
and I think our favorite thing with the
show is that
people started thinking one thing and
they end it and they're like what the
hell did I just watch I can imagine that
uh we would take it in a different
direction like a very different uh
feeling show I mean I feel like season
two has its it comes with its a very
very different energy and I'm sure that
we would carry on kind of trying to
surprise people and entertain people I
mean I'm a sucker for a good love
triangle and so I think that'd be a fun
thing to play with and you know just
seeing how Zion navigates moving on from
Georgia as he's doing already you know
but I think you know the lifeblood of
any romantic you know
series or you know what we're doing is
there's some love triangles you know and
I think that'd be a fun thing to play
with I think she needs to stick with one
boy at a time but um it would be it
would be fun I don't know the show
creators have brains that move faster
than I can even think and so we'll see
what they have in store I want to see
Ginny like happy for once that'd be nice
I would like for her to just like be
happy for more than an episode at a time
um I don't know
um I I do know some of the ideas that
they they do have for if we were to be
lucky enough to have more seasons
um and it terrifies me I'm not gonna lie
to you it terrifies me is it a musical
is season three a musical should I take
lessons
okay just wink if I need to take tap
lessons
tapping is big on our show what we're
gonna be doing
okay
foreign